you're a new TV dad you have a baby yeah
so have you ever do you like Allison you
change the diaper right well luckily on
set we don't I don't have to change any
of the diapers and when you're a TV dad
you know it's like there's like multiple
children we have triplets we had twins
on the show that I did right that looked
nothing alike by the way I'm like
there's one okay because babies can only
work like 13 minutes a day which is a
appropriate amount of work to make a
baby do because they didn't sign up no I
don't change any of the diapers I think
that's unfair I want to see an Instagram
of you changing a diaper little boy then
you got to make sure that diaper goes on
quick let's just put a shine yeah sure
have you competed on in the face I have
I'm sure I don't have like little caps
you do I use like you know those pads
when you're when you're breastfeeding
those little cap yeah I just you know
[Laughter]
you can get kind of messy I want I want
a messy diaper that you have to change
that's how that's the kind of fun I am
up you know what I'll do it I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this